this is probably gonna be a very
emotional video for you to watch let me
explain to you why that is listen
anytime you and I go to two different
places in our lives everybody you have a
lot of people that I've lived with you
mom dad brother sister friends wife boy
all this stuff you've had but there's
only one person that's lived with you
every second of your life and that's you
right we get emotional thinking about
our kids or mom dad but there's a whole
different emotional aspect when you go
back and you think about the 6-year over
of you and where you were thinking about
memory you know how you take a picture
and you look at the picture when you
were six and it has a fear in their eyes
or you were afraid you like man what
were you thinking about you know what
was this kid thinking about a picture of
myself I look at it it's turmoil Iran
I'm like kid what are you thinking about
and I get emotional and on the flip side
of it you're gonna think about the 40
row version of you 60 70 that gets you
emotional because what is life going to
be like am I going to reach my full
potential that is a scary thought by the
way you know why because no one else
matters in this world when it comes down
to that it's only you versus you nobody
does not your competitors nothing and so
think about life as a video game you
ever played a video game before say
Mario say you play an RPG role-playing
game the whole idea the video game is to
do what is to move up another level
another level and as the levels go
higher the game gets tougher but you
also become tougher right as you're
leveling up can you imagine playing a
video again with 20 levels and never
getting past level 5 can you imagine
that you know what's crazy
most people play life like that they
never get past level 5 so I told you
could be emotional here today my goal
today with this video I only have 20
minutes with you I wish I had a whole
day with you two days with you my idea
with this video today so to get you to
start thinking about what your potential
is what is your true capacity why not
someone like you wake up today and say
you know what it's about time I go seek
my capacity rather than just live in a
regular life
[Music]
so you know a lot of times people tell
you and say well you got to reach your
full potential and people say what is
potential I don't know what that even
means you got to reach your capacity I'm
gonna explain to you three different
things today and then I'll give you my
points at the end one is your capacity
may be different than somebody else's
capacity that's number one - what
happens why we're afraid to reach our
capacity we'll talk a little bit about
that in a very simple way 3 what are the
areas of capacity that I really have I
don't even know what that really means
I'll break down for you and I'll give
you some tips I could put 60 points you
but I'm gonna simplify and just give you
some of the points that maybe I haven't
heard of before so let's get right into
a look you have to accept a couple
things here this is an example of three
different human beings each with a
different level of capacity this
person's capacity the person number 3
this person's capacity makes him right
here
he doesn't have where she doesn't have
his capacity okay this person can reach
at their maximum capacity and give
everything in life and above it beyond
everybody else in a certain industry and
they can never compete with this
person's capacity and then you have
these guys who have more talents than
other people who have more access to
resources than other people their
capacity is higher and that's okay
you're watching us right now saying Pat
I kind of don't like that what I mean
you don't like that well I feel I can be
anything in life because my mom told me
I can be anything in life your mom lied
you can't be anything in life you can't
be LeBron James you cannot be Usain Bolt
you can't that has to do with the body
let me explain what I mean by this in a
sports example and then you can
understand it for yourself red means
somebody who is an underachiever
say this is you you stay here you're an
underachiever blue means you're an
achiever you did good
you want to achieved at the level that
you should have Green is what you were
supposed to do you did but you took it
to a whole different level and you
became an overachiever where no one
expected you to reach you reached
that's a whole different idea let me
explain again here we can talk about a
guy named Mugsy Bogues he gets drafted
in the NBA he is five three a hundred
and thirty five pounds let me say this
one more time he's five three 135 pounds
he plays fourteen seasons in the NBA at
5-3 135 pounds average and eight assists
a game he is an overachiever because no
one in the history of the NBA has ever
been five three shortest player ever
that guy goes right up here as an
achiever
he's an overachiever let's put it over
here Shaq most people would say is an
overachiever
I don't put Shaq as an overachiever I
put Shaq as an achiever why you're seven
one okay you got big hands size 24 feet
massive strong powerful you can push
every body around Shaq could have been
the greatest basketball player of all
time not one of the greatest now top ten
greatest he could have been the greatest
we've never seen a human being like that
before no history of sports comes in 71
320 340 pounds and he's got hops and
he's fast he could have been the
greatest offseason he put on weight
never practiced his free throws as much
as he could have been what if Shaq
practice is free-throw and started
shooting 73% instead of 59% what if Shaq
you know added another footwork during
the time he was playing he was playing
against Hakeem Olajuwon what if he went
and got a couple other footwork so what
if he did better conditioning during
offseason what if they took care of
himself
maybe Shaq could have been averaging 38
points a game maybe shot could have been
known 16 rebounds he may be shot could
have been doing 71 a percent free-throw
showing what happened there see to me
he's an achiever but Mugsy Bogues is an
overachiever but even though Mugsy
Bogues is an overachiever he'll never be
a Shaq cuz shack at achiever is still
better than Mugsy Bogues however when
Mugsy Bogues goes to sleep at night he
needs to know that he reached he's an
overachiever in life in every body in
his industry respects him that's the
part so now for you watching it's like
what path how do I know what my
that he is what is my potential you
generally know if you're more talented
than most people around you you do you
generally know about you know it you
know it if you are you generally know if
you're just a simple person in your
entire life you've just been a simple
person maybe your level is gonna be not
that crazy you generally know but
regardless where you're at you have your
capacity okay and you get to choose what
you want to be so now you may say Pat it
explained to me capacity what is
capacity let me explain to you
capacity is your day how do you maximize
your day what is your capacity for today
did you maximize your capacity today do
you maximize on a daily basis or do you
wink half the time with your days your
capacities your network do you really
take advantage your network your context
you have the people you know do you
maximize it do you have your capacity
where you know who to call favors give
them favors connect get these two that
would work it together do you maximize
your network your money that you have or
does it just kind of sit there do you
maximize the tools that you have around
you social media you know this this
thing is purely a tool this is nothing
more than a tool do you maximize this
tool do you maximize this social media
stuff that's out there are you using it
or not I don't know you know it do you
maximize your talents your talents the
abilities that you have if you were to
ask the top five people that know you
very well and that you would ask what
are my most talented and a top five
talents that I have people will say
you're an amazing communicator let me
take your so intuitive you can always
reach somebody you know if that person
is a good person or not you always know
if somebody someone else you trust or
not your intuition is amazing man you
are so good when it comes on to making
people feel good you're so good with
math you're so good with science you're
so good with this people will tell you
what you're good at you know it you've
heard it multiple times in your life
before are you maximizing your talents
are you really doing that last one your
advisors you have advisors you have
Mentors
I run a company with 8500 agents right
now we're in 40 United States I have a
sixth Chairman's counsel eleven senior
vice president's a few hundred marketing
directors right but not everybody's
using each other's advice we'll do a
conference call on a weekly
cases and one not everybody will ask
questions the conference call with 12
people not everybody asked questions why
are they not leveraging their advisers
why they're not asking questions why is
that is it ego I can ask anything why
they're not using their capacity so
capacity and life isn't just your talent
that you have in your life it's
everybody around you everything you have
access to
that's capacity so now let's answer the
question why don't people reach their
capacity it's very simple remember
earlier I told you life is like a video
game and you got to go to the next level
this this part's gonna make a lot of
sense to you and it's gonna be difficult
for you to embrace this but let me
explain it to you here's what it is
everybody in life if these are levels at
some level you're in the top 20% let me
explain everybody is in the top 20% of
some level here what here's what I mean
say you play basketball you could be the
best basketball player if you play
against seventh graders and your senior
well you're the best basketball player
no one can push you around but you're
not getting better but you're in the top
1% of basketball players amongst 13 year
olds you're 18 but most people treat
their careers that way just so you know
that most people are 18 euros playing
basketball against 13 year olds you ever
hear is senior in high school that got
into a fight with a freshman what do you
call that senior a bully most people
treat their careers that way most people
would hire potential they're lazy they
don't put a lot of work believe me I
mentor a lot of people that I've seen
here their capacity is here but they're
secretly so lazy they don't put the work
in because they can wing it and they're
still beating this guy so they think
they're doing so well but they're not
they're just bullying somebody below
them they're not good they can't compete
with somebody at their own level no way
they'll get smashed by somebody that's
really wanting to reach their capacity
at their level so they like to be around
guys like this because it validates how
good they are very interesting place to
be that's a person that never goes to
the next level because every time you go
to the next level you're in the bottom
80% and it sucks
every time every single time you go to a
new levels like oh my gosh I don't even
know what to do with this one you know
how you play video game you get to the
new level you lose
loose loose but the level prior to that
you I can do this with my eyes closed
Papa Papa Papa Papa boom next level you
lose takes you 30 times before you go to
the next level so you don't like that
lever you like to go to the level behind
you that's life every single time you
level up to get your capacity you suck
at the next level we hate sucking at any
level you and I we hate sucking we had a
visit this last week I was in LA for
poker tournament we had Kevin Hart I was
hosting a charity tournament and we gave
away twenty five thousand dollars to
charity at Kevin Hart there invited Phil
Hellmuth and I had Michael Franzese and
twenty other friends we had some of our
executives I rented this seventy five
million dollar penthouse 26 thousand
square feet and we had a good time
everybody showed up were playing a game
afterwards we go to dinner I think we
went to Fleming's one of the
conversations came up and one of the
guys said you know it's crazy in life
you make the money and then once you
make it look oh man I made it what do I
do now the journey is what's exciting I
said I disagree says what I mean you
disagree I said you only feel you got
there if you stop there if you keep
going to the next level you suck at the
next level you're not doing anything at
the next level so here's what that
example is here's a human being they've
reached here they're beating most people
they think they've reached it they have
no idea that there's that level there
because there's fear and every time you
and I believe me I know this for my
experience every time people that tell
you oh my gosh is so amazing
you're so dis you're so great Wow
Patrick Wow Johnny Wow Steve Wow Bobby
boom you believe it
but you're not there yet because you
haven't reached your capacity yet are
you really maximizing these things are
you really fully yes huh I don't know
about that we were talking earlier and
for me when I was putting this content
to get on and I were talking I said you
know a lot of people may think I'm an
overachiever in my eyes I'm an achiever
still I am still an achiever but Pat you
run a business you didn't have a degree
you come from a divorced family you
lived in Iran with a war you live in a
refugee camp
you want to high school 1.8 GPA you know
what
mean you run a YouTube channel what a
million subs insurance companies growing
nobody expected you to do any of this
stuff yes but in my mind I don't care
what the world is saying in my mind I
don't want to believe I'm an
overachiever because if I'm an
overachiever I've reached it I don't
want to think that I've reached it I
want to know there's ten more levels to
the game what am I gonna play a game
that I'm almost finished a game I want a
new level I want two more levels I want
to know there's twenty more levels above
me you want to know there's twenty more
levels above you what if you meet the
best version of you remember how earlier
I told you this is an emotional video
because you go back and look at that
six-year-old picture and you remember
that kid had dreams remember that kid
had dreams remember what that kid
thought he could do she could do do you
remember that day you remembered that I
remember that day fear there's a walk I
remember every single time people tell
me what's the earliest memory of your
childhood that was six years old I was
going down the street we lived in a
wonderful jazz Street or jet I was
walking to the left to pick up milk from
the side when I went over there I walked
by myself I was so afraid I was so
afraid I remember exactly the street I
was on I was so afraid so afraid I was
just like oh my god I don't know why one
day I don't know why one day I just want
to God one day please I don't but I'm
afraid like this whole emotion you know
exactly what I'm talking about and this
isn't something you can act you know it
I know it but can you imagine living
your whole I've never experiencing that
drink that potential that capacity what
our life what a waste you know that
already you know wake up every single
they wanted to contribute to another TV
commercial or another ad on YouTube or
Facebook or any of this other stuff
no you wake up every day suck man what
if what if I give it never be afraid of
sucking at the next level so let me give
you some pointers this is how I process
capacity for myself and hopefully this
think this can help you out by the way I
have a bunch of points you're okay let
me read you some of the points yet but
I'm not gonna cover with you here okay
write down your goals avoid the
realistic and seek the potential take
massive action stop being poor stay
persistent you know visualize
imagination stop apologizing hundred
percent responsibility focus on a bigger
picture these are all right they're all
right but you can watch them read
all these other books I've written about
of myself in other videos and other
books I've written but I'm gonna give
you stuff maybe you haven't heard of
before
number one it must matter to you it has
to matter to you let me put it to you
this way this whatever mine is like this
tears I can immediately I can start
crying thinking about it okay because it
matters to me
yesterday we're at Thanksgiving dinner
we're all asked a question because she
was trying to announce something to us
she says how what are you most grateful
for everybody gives her great gratitude
my turns coming up what do you want to
say family that's this death I said
honestly for me the first sum of my life
were I feel better some stability I said
what do you mean I said I've never had
stable it in my life what do you mean
over had stability in your life in Iran
never Germany refugee camp never living
in a u.s. parents divorced back and
forth see my dad live on my mom there
was no stability there joining the army
no stability there coming out of the
Army trying to figure out what it is to
be a civilian getting a job trying to
pay off my forty nine thousand dollars
there's no stability they're getting
into financial services trying to figure
out how to sell all this stuff and
running a lease changing the offices
money that there's no stability there
starting an insurance company at thirty
years old where the average insurance
agent is fifty nine and the average CEO
is 65 years old there's no stability
there there is no middle-eastern CEO
there everybody's white with nice
degrease and I'm not one of those guys
that connects with everybody and I don't
like to be a victim I feel sorry for
myself and say what Patrick it's because
you're Iranian this is why if I was
white I don't like those kinds of alibis
and excuses I don't have any stability I
don't have money backing me up yes we
erased ten million dollars last year but
I was last year at 39 years old I don't
use anybody's money I save my own money
I sound like you're my own money if
you're gonna pull this off you gotta be
able to pull it off I don't like that I
don't like owing people money you can be
a pull-off no stability for some of my
career I'm 40 years old I'm experiencing
a bit of stability and different aspects
of my life I'm trusting my
decision-making process better you
consume I Contin do you think I know
everything I don't know everything
I'm still learning because I'm seeking
this this is what I'm after
and it matters to me I'm breathing heart
cuz this this hurts me this excites me
this is life to me this is my heartbeat
I don't know any other way of doing this
it's entire day I had to make this
content in my mind I'm like god this is
too emotional for me to make this
content but it matters to me it has to
matter to you meaning that 59 year old
person that's reached a capacitor you
have 59 that's got a matter to you if it
matters to you you just subtly need a
few strategies that benefits your number
two there's a difference between
initiating and reacting listen there are
leaders in life and there are chasers in
life chasers chase the leader okay at
some point in your life you are chasing
don't get me wrong
at some point in your life you are
chasing you could be chasing your dad it
could be chasing your mom you could be
chasing your older brother you go to
chasing your older sister your older
friends in school but it comes to a
moment in your life where you got to
take initiative
you gotta initiate you can't wait for
everybody to read if something happens
then you react to it you gotta initiate
you got a lead you gotta be the lion at
one point of your life you got to see
all this time I've been a cat all this
time I've been at all this time I've
been exact it's time I'm a lion now boom
and when you decide to become one your
wiring has to change you can't wait for
everybody else to do something then you
react to them you don't go hit the
weights because somebody else is hitting
the weight you hit the weights because
you're trying to increase your energy
you don't get to work because somebody
else is working you get into work
because you're leading everybody because
you lead or not a chaser
to reach your capacity you can't be a
chaser all the time eventually you have
to graduate being a chaser and some
total sum tells me most of you guys are
chasers most of you guys are people that
are you know waiting to react to
something happening capacity requires
you to lead and to initiate you can't
chase and react all the time number
three I talk systems a lot I'm gonna
talk a lot about systems at our first
vitamin conference here will soon it
announced it's gonna be three-day
conference I'm gonna spend a lot of time
with systems with you but you got to
have systems let me
spend what systems do in the book the
power of habit the author talks about
the fact that our brain is naturally
lazy and our brain likes to come up with
systems because it doesn't want to think
it just wants to do right there are a
lot of things you do you don't think
about like you don't have a to do list
brush my teeth in the morning it's a
system and you have a system on how you
brush or do you think about it you put
the toothpaste on first maybe you do a
long one small one maybe I don't know
how you do it
maybe you go like this maybe you start
off like this I don't know what you do
we have a system do what you brush your
teeth right now you have a system down
how you do it think about it right so
you're no longer think about how to
brush your teeth you're showering I
don't know if you go like this first or
you go like his first I don't know if
you go here I don't know what you do you
have a system if you think about how you
shower it's a system you don't think
about the way you do it washing your
hands how do you wash your hand do you
go soap
boom-boom-boom or do you go water soap
water boom-boom-boom do you go water you
know boom boom boom soap boom boom what
do you do you have a system you don't
think about you've done a million times
in business you have to take this stuff
that you're thinking about doing come up
with systems so you don't think about it
anymore
and it just happens everything in life
you got to create systems for the more
systems you have leads me to the next
point you can serve energy when you
conserve energy that energy is put into
the bigger things that gets you to what
your capacity but you got to conserve
your energy let me see one more time
when you create systems on things that
happen you're not wasting your energy on
small stuff you're investing your energy
into big stuff because you're conserving
it because you have systems and then
when you put it into the big stuff boom
growth happens I don't know what I would
be busy I'm like oh my god what do I
create a video called how to strategize
as an entrepreneur my favorite video of
all time doesn't have that many views by
far my favorite video of all time
because when I was coming up as a sales
gonna become sales in like what do I do
right now I don't feel like I have
anything to do energy pick up the phone
call clients pick up the phone you meet
with clients pick up the phone
meet with agents pick up the phone get
off the internet stop doing the
paperwork stop doing all this stuff pick
up the phone
go meet with somebody most productive
thing I could do is sit right in front
somebody touch
sell them something teach them something
get some referrals connect next
what's my productive that requires
energy to be in the conversation in the
moment when they're telling me I'm
listening so I can remember Sky's
birthday's coming up in two weeks this
guy's wife's birthday he said he likes
us make him know - but you're gonna send
him a card you gonna send him that
brochure from the Jaguar dealership
because he lacks the Jaguar you're
making notes you're making notes
conserving energy so I'm staying in a
moment make sense I don't want to waste
it because I have systems next point you
got to move on faster you can't stay in
the moment of a loss or a setback for
too long I have this one person that's
been trying to get ahold of me all day
today you know why I haven't called this
person back here's what haven't called
this person back they had they're
dealing with a crisis today last two
years two and a half years do you
realize every six months they've had a
massive crisis why why because every
time a crisis happened I did they lagged
fixing the issue so it became bigger
okay they lack or they kept doing the
same thing and not realizing it's been
that's the mistake not the other people
how are you having the same issue with
five different people I promise you that
the people it's you so I want to fix
this truck and move on faster if I'm
constantly trying to fix everybody I'm
the problem for the rest of my life I
had a loss they rejected they cancel
they change their mind so what what can
I do right now to conserve it can I keep
this client a medium on call Mary is
there anything I can do what happened
did I say something to upset you did I
first at you was it and misunderstand
typically some happens please tell me
you know what Patrick I don't know to
someone you said I don't like it when he
said it's my apologist that's not what I
meant that's what I was trying to say I
am so sorry about the fact that you felt
that way was that really the only thing
yes is there anything I can do to earn
your business again yes just the fact
that you called I feel a lot better
because I thought my wife was a little
bit Oh Mary I would never say something
like that to offend you never have so
much respect for you and your family on
what you've done you know I'm simply
trying to assist you and helping you get
you in a better direction oh well thank
you so much so based on what we're
talking do I still have I still earned
your business
yes great let's move forward so that's
like okay if I can't
great I'm moving on you've got to be
able to do it because if
you don't want you won't reach you
you're always gonna be here you're
always gonna be here always here that's
capacity next six define hard work okay
a lot of it's hard work I'm working 100
hours a week 80 hours a week social
media doing what what are you doing 100
hours a week
what are you doing 100 dollars what are
you doing 60 hours what are you doing 80
hours a week
define hard work so we need to find hard
works and you put hours towards every
activity when I do this is 30 minutes it
should take me 30 minutes if it takes
you two hours you wasted an hour and a
half when I make this phone call average
phone call is six minutes if they pick
up 38 minutes what happened there why
are you over selling what happened there
when I go and do a drop I do this this
one I do this takes this when I'm doing
as it takes this define hard work and
put hours and time to every single
activity that you do whatever that
activity is define it with minutes with
seconds with hours number capacity do
you want to meet your capacity you got
to put it there right and last but not
least compete up don't be afraid I said
earlier don't be afraid to suck at the
next level do not be afraid to suck at
the next level because the reality part
of life is if you're able to do this if
you're not afraid of any of this stuff
one day you'll be able to say I reached
it and even when you get in that moment
and everybody tells you that mindset of
being an overachiever the experiences
you experience are priceless it's
priceless and that a habit of you
wanting to seek this you know who also
it rubs off of that everybody that's
around you your co-workers your kids
your family or spouse your peers you're
gonna rub some people the wrong way and
you have to understand why that is I
have a lot of friends that don't like me
anymore they still love me at one point
because I was stuck at this level and
they were here so they were glad I was
making 36 can they were making 59 K they
liked it the moment I made quarter
million didn't like me anymore I had
people that were making a half a million
I was making a quarter me and they loved
me the moment I started making three
million years they didn't like me
anymore I had people that were making
three million I wouldn't make I was week
and a half and really they loved me
their life great then also I go 200
million they don't like me anymore
this is like and then you have some
people like oh my gosh
dude what are you doing I want to learn
let's go hey I just want to be around
man let's go hang out what can we do cut
then it's like da da da da that's
exciting right that's because you're
seeking this and that wiring if you get
this wiring and you start thinking that
way like I said this is emotional you
may need to watch this whole thing again
- actually could you watch this video
came on your phone like oh great - a
parrot or Barry Taylor sick oh my gosh
this is an emotional video you can't
just watch this video and drive the car
you got to rewind take the notes you got
to experience the moment and by the way
if you watched it while you're taking
notes turn everything off look at your
notes internalize this feeling right now
don't let this feeling go go with it
think about it how are you feeling right
now
are you afraid what makes feelings do
you have right now is it excitement joy
anxiety happiness fear all combined
sometimes the best food you eat that
recipes technical sometimes reaching
your capacity that's a technical recipe
that doesn't make any sense that
includes fear and anxiety and that's
okay it's like the hot sauce in life use
it don't let it go so now you watched it
you take notes now you get to a place
you feel good about it you're in a good
state second video I want you to watch
this it's how to build a life plan it's
a one-page business plan click on this
it's that time of the year
one-page business plan write your
one-page business plan the goal is
capacity and once you experience this I
want to know exactly what you're
thinking as you're watching this video I
want to know your feelings when you're
watching this video send me a tweet at
Patrick we're David
and if you haven't subscribed to this
channel click on the subscribe button
take care love you
you